Here's what we were thinking.
What if we did for mortgages what the Internet did for buying music...
...and plane tickets and shoes?
You would turn an intimidating process into an easy one.
You could get a mortgage on your phone.
And if it could be that easy,...
...wouldn't more people buy homes?
And wouldn't those buyers need to fill their homes...
...with lamps and blenders and sectional couches with hand-lathed wooden legs?
And wouldn't that mean all sorts of wooden leg making opportunities...
...for wooden leg makers?
And wouldn't those new leg makers own phones...
...from which they could quickly and easily secure mortgages of their own,...
...further stoking demand for necessary household goods?
Thus, our tidal wave of ownership floods the country with new homeowners...
...who now must own other things.
And isn't that the power of America itself?
Now shrunk to fit the hands of a child...
...or more helpfully, a home buying adult.
Anyway, that's what we were thinking.
Rocket.